WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG SATURDAY
SHOW, OFFICIALS IN TWO STATES
ARE STILL COUNTING VOTES FROM
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
WHERE'S PRESIDENT BIDEN?
OVERSEAS PUSHING CLIMATE CHANGE
AGENDA AND APOLOGIZING.
>> PREVENT GOOD CLIMATE POLICY
IS GOOD ECONOMIC POLICY.
WE REJOINED THE PARIS AGREEMENT.
WE CONVENED MAJOR CLIMATE
SUMMIT.
I APOLOGIZE WE EVER PULLED OUT.
IT'S MORE URGENT THAN EVER WE
DOUBLE DOWN ON CLIMATE
COMMITMENTS.
RUSSIA'S WAR ONLY ENHANCES
URGENCY OF THE NEED TO
TRANSITION THE WORLD OFF
DEPENDENCE ON FOSSIL FUELS.
>> UNBELIEVABLE AND NANCY PELOSI
JUMPING ON BOARD PUTTING OUT A
STATEMENT, AMERICA IS ALL IN TO
FIGHT THE CLIMATE RISES, NOTHING
CAN DETER DEMOCRATS FROM URGENT
MISSION TO SAVE THE PLANET.
I WISH THEY WOULD START WITH
SAYING THE COUNTRY BUT OKAY.
JOE BIDEN TOLD US HE LEARNED
NOTHING FROM THE ELECTION,
NOTHING TO LEARN, HE'LL KEEP
DOING WHAT HE'S DOING AND THEY
ARE COMMITTED TO THIS REVISION
OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
WHAT HAPPENS -- OBVIOUSLY THE
CHICKENS COME HOME TO ROOST AND
PAY A PRICE AT SOME TIME.
>> THEIR COMING HOME TO ROOST
WHETHER IT'S NOT CAUSING THEM
ELECTIONS IS ONE THING WE COULD
DEBATE SEPARATELY BUT IT'S
COSTING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
EVEN THOUGH INFLATION NUMBERS
HAVE COME DOWN, CPI CAME DOWN TO
7.7% YEAR-OVER-YEAR, A WHOPPING
NUMBER.
MOST AMERICANS ARE SAYING THEY
DON'T SEE THE RELIEF AT THE PUMP
THEY WANT TO SEE OR FOOD PRICES
COMING DOWN THE WAY THEY WANT TO
SEE THEM AHEAD OF THE HOLIDAYS
SO LOOK AT THE CLIMATE CHANGE
AGENDA AND WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
THE ENERGY INDUSTRY YOU REALIZE
INFLATION WILL NEVER COME DOWN
UNTIL WE SOLVE THE PROBLEM
REVAMPING OIL PRODUCTION HERE IN
THE U.S. WITH DIESEL PRICES
WHERE THEY ARE OVER $5 A GALLON
IT'S EMBEDDED IN EVERYTHING YOU
SEE, FEEL AND TOUCH IF THEY ARE
NOT LOSING ELECTIONS, YOU AND I
ARE LOSING BECAUSE WE ARE PAYING
THE PRICE.
>> FOR ME THAT'S WHAT'S MOST
DISAPPOINTING ABOUT THE LOSSES,
NOT JUST HAVING MAJORITY OR PUT
THE LEGISLATIVE AGENDA,
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT GOING TO
REALIZE THE PAIN OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY SAY PEOPLE
MUST NOT HAVE IT THAT BAD
BECAUSE THEY STILL VOTED FOR US
AND THAT WILL HURT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT ENERGY
PRODUCTION, THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE WE THOUGHT IF WE WERE
ABLE TO DO THAT ARE IN THE
MIDTERMS AND DEMOCRATS WOULD
HAVE TO REALIZE STATES LIKE MINE
MATTERS, THE COAL JOBS MATTER.
DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION BIDEN
SAYING HE GET RID OF THE COAL
INDUSTRY AND PRESS SECRETARY
SAYING HE DIDN'T WANT TO GET RID
OF THE COAL INDUSTRY, NOW THEY
GOING FULL ON AND NOW AVERAGE
AMERICANS ARE GOING TO SUFFER
AND OIL RESERVES ARE LOW AND WE
ARE ALL SUFFERING.
>> DOES ANYBODY WANT TO MAKE A
BET WHETHER GAS PRICES WILL GO
UP OR DOWN?
YOU WON'T FIND ANYBODY ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
TALKING ABOUT SAVING THE COUNTRY
BEFORE THE PLANET, LISTEN TO
THIS FROM HENRY CUELLAR WHO JUST
WON REELECTION IN TEXAS, LISTEN
TO WHAT HE TOLD NEIL CAVUTO.
>> I HAD TALKED TO HIM SINCE.
>> BIDEN SINCE HE WAS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENCY, NOT SINCE HE GOT
THE PRESIDENCY?
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
AGAIN, THERE ARE STAFF WHO GET
IN BETWEEN, I TALKED TO THE
SECRETARY AND A BUNCH OF FOLKS
AT THE WHITE HOUSE BUT HIM?
NO BUT I OFFER MYSELF AS A
RESOURCE PERSON BECAUSE I DON'T
JUST VISIT THE BORDER, I LIVE
HERE AT THE BORDER.
>> IS THE ONLY BLUE DOG DEMOCRAT
LEFT IN CONGRESS, THE ONLY SANE
DEMOCRAT LEFT TALKING ABOUT
ISSUES THAT MATTER TO THE
COUNTRY.
THE PARTY DOESN'T PAY ATTENTION
TO HIM.
>> THEY DON'T WANT TO ADMIT
THERE'S A PROBLEM AT THE BORDER
WITH THAT'S BEEN THE CONTINUING
CONVERSATION SINCE BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE AND APPOINTED KAMALA
HARRIS AS BORDER CZAR AND HASN'T
SPENT TIME AT THE BORDER IF THEY
AVOID THE ISSUE, PEOPLE WON'T
UNDERSTAND LARGELY THEY ARE
RIGHT BECAUSE BILL MELUGIN OF
FOX NEWS IS THE ONLY ONE THING
ATTENTION FROM THE MEDIA, IT'S A
BIG PROBLEM AND BIDEN IS GETTING
AWAY WITH IT.
>> GOOD FOR HIM FOR BEING RIGHT
ON A LOT OF ISSUES BUT YOU HAVE
TO PUNISH THE PARTY AND VOTE
PEOPLE OUT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE -- IF THEY DON'T GET
TRACTION WITHIN THE PARTY YOU
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO REMOVE
THEM.
>> WE REPUBLICANS DIDN'T WIN,
THEY WENT TO THE BORDER,
SCREAMED WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
SAID DEMOCRATS ARE DOING ENOUGH
AND WE WANT TO SHUT THE BORDER
DOWN AND AMERICANS SAID IT'S NOT
A SOLUTION AND WE NEED MORE AND
THEY HAVE TO TAKE THAT TO HEART
COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS TO GET
PAST.
FOR THE FIRST TIME SEE THE
BORDER AS MORE, SEE IT FOR THE
ISSUE IT IS, BRING A SOLUTION
THAT ISN'T EVERYTHING YOU WANT
BUT WORKS AND SELL US ON IT.
THE ONE THING DEMOCRATS CAN DO
IS NAME A BILL.
THEY EVEN NAMED RON DESANTIS
DON'T SAY GAY BILL FOR HIM.
COME UP WITH ONE THAT SOUNDS
GOOD AND SELL IT.
>> IN CASE YOU HAVE FAITH LEFT
WILL BIDEN HAS ANY IDEA WHAT'S
GOING ON OR WHETHER HE EVEN
KNOWS WHERE HE IS, LISTEN.
>> I WANT TO THANK THE PRIME
MINISTER FOR COLUMBIA'S
LEADERSHIP AND FOR HOSTING ALL
OF US.
>> I'M HEADING TO COLUMBIA AND
THEN CAMBODIA, THE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE.
>> DOES HE EVEN KNOW?
>> MY FAVORITE CARTOON IS PORKY
PIG, THAT'S WHAT HE SOUNDS LIKE.
THIS IS THE BLOCK WE ARE IN, I
TALKED TO SOMEBODY AT THE TOP 27
GOT A QUOTE, DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
CLIMATE COLONIALISM TRYING TO
BUY ALLEGIANCE AND SELL
COUNTRIES THAT CAN'T AFFORD IT
ON SOMETHING WE CAN'T AFFORD
OURSELVES.
DEMOCRATS ATTACKING THE CLEANEST
FOSSIL FUEL IN THE WORLD, THE
WAY WE GOT TO THE OMISSIONS
WE'VE MADE IS BY REPLACING COAL
WITH LIQUID NATURAL GAS AND NOW
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY WITH
GAS TERMINALS, EVERYTHING WE
NEED FOR CLEAN FOSSIL FUEL AND
THEY ARE DOING IT SO WE ARE THE
DIRTIEST ONES AND SAY WE NEED